There are thousands of refugees entering
Bangladesh every day. They cross the
border of Myanmar where the state
military has launched a violent
offensive against an ethnic minority
group – the Rohingya. The UN reported
that since August 2017 about 400,000
Rohingya men women and children have
fled their homes in Myanmar's Rakhine
State. Reports claimed that the military
has been killing and raping the Rohingya
and has set their villages on fire.
Satellite imagery showing burned
villages confirms those reports.
Because Myanmar has refused access to human rights investigators, the current
situation cannot yet be fully assessed
but the situation remains or seems a
textbook example of ethnic
cleansing. The term ethnic cleansing has
been reserved for some of the worst
atrocities in history. The UN defines it
as a purposeful policy designed by one
ethnic or religious group to remove by
violent and terror inspiring means the
civilian population of another ethnic or
religious group from certain geographic
areas.
What makes Myanmar a textbook example is that the military has been launching
attacks on the Rohingya – a Muslim
minority in a majority Buddhist country.
Violent tactics have forced tens of
thousands of Rohingya to flee their
homes. While many fled to Malaysia and
Thailand most ended up in Bangladesh.
The recent wave of violence is the latest in a pattern of discrimination that started
over 50 years ago. In 1962, Myanmar –
then called Burma – was taken over by the
military in a coup. They got rid of the
country's constitution and created a
military junta. Like many dictatorships
they promoted fierce nationalism based
on the country's Buddhist identity and
when they needed a common enemy to help
unite the population the Rohingya were
singled out as a threat. Tensions between
the Burmese Buddhist population and the
Rohingya go back to the Second World War
when each group supported opposing sides. The Rohingya sided with the British
colonialists who ruled the country and
the Buddhists mostly sided with the
Japanese invaders hoping they'd help end
the British rule after the war. But even
in modern Myanmar the Rohingya
minority continued to be an easy target.
Although their lineage can be traced
back to 15th century Burma, the
government has been forcing them out
claiming their illegal immigrants from
Bangladesh.
It started in 1978 after a massive
crackdown called Operation Dragon King
forced about 200,000 Rohingya to flee to
Bangladesh. The military reportedly used
violence and rape to drive them out.
About a hundred and seventy thousand Rohingya reportedly returned to Burma. Then
in 1982, the government passed the
Citizenship Act recognizing 135 ethnic
groups. The Rohingya, with a population
of about 1 million, were not on the list
and became a stateless people. In 1991,
Myanmar's military launched another
campaign literally called "Operation
clean and beautiful nation." This time
about 250,000 Rohingya fled to
Bangladesh. Tensions continued to build
against the Rohingya in the 2000s. Violence broke out in 2012
when four Muslim men were accused of
raping and killing a buddhist woman in
Rakhine. Buddhist nationalist backed by
security forces attacked Muslim
neighborhoods, burned homes displacing
tens of thousands of Rohingya again.
Human Rights Watch deemed it an ethnic
cleansing campaign. By this point the
Rohingya were persecuted
disenfranchised and stateless. In 2016, a
Rohingya militant group, the Arakan Rohingya Salvation Army, emerged and
coordinated small-scale attacks on
border police stations. An attack on
August 25th 2017 left 12 police officers
dead and sparked the current crisis
against Rohingya civilians. A brutal
retaliation by the state security forces
has led to about 400 deaths and the mass
exodus of about 400,000 Rohingya to
Bangladesh. Since the August attack 210
villages have been burned to the ground.
The violent campaign has triggered the
fastest growing humanitarian crisis in
recent years, but Myanmar's de facto
leader and Nobel Peace Prize winner
Aung San Suu Ky has barely acknowledged the attacks.
More than 50% of the villages of Muslims
are intact they are as they were before
the attacks took place. When she says
that, you know, 50% of the Muslim villages
are still present in Rakhine State wel,l
I mean, what are we talking about? 50% are
gone. 50% are burnt out. You know in any school
I went to 50% is a failing grade. Recent
reports claimed that the military has
planted landmines along the Bangladesh
border to prevent the Rohingya from
returning. Myanmar's government has systematically
driven the Rohingya out of the country.
Over the last five decades it has
stripped their citizenship, terrorized
them, and destroyed their homes, and now
it wants to keep them from ever coming
back.